This is one of my least favorites. This is called the "limp fish."
How's it going?
Pretty good.
I mean, did he just die?
"Stick shift": one party goes for the fist bump,...
...the other party goes for the regular handshake.
It's a nightmare scenario when both parties switch to alternate forms...
...at the last possible second.
I want to go home.
The "moist palm."
How's it going?
Hey, I'm good. How are you?
This next one's called the "showdown."
You hold down a little too long and squeeze a little more tightly,...
...trying to assert your manliness over the other party,...
...never breaking eye contact.
Hey, how's it going?
I'm pretty good, how are you?
I'm good.
How are you?
Did you try the chips?
Good.
Delicious.
Really good guac, isn't it?
Yeah.
This next one's called the "dap."
Thumb over thumb, hand in hand, light chest bump/hug.
Give me some of that.
You good, man?
Yeah, I'm great.
Put the cherry on top with that one and add a "bro" in the end.
What's up, bro?
This next one's called the "dap gone wrong."
One person thinks it's a handshake, the other one thinks it's a hug.
It just leads to this mess of uncomfortable weirdness.
Hey, what's up man?
This is called the "hail Caesar."
You're at the gym. Your buddy introduces you to somebody.
You go to shake his hand. He goes right past your hand...
...and grabs your forearm like a Greco-Roman wrestler.
Good to meet you.
What, is he going to shoot the leg now?
Best handshake, in my opinion, of all time is just a great, firm handshake.
Get in, get out, get it done.